تقترب الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه من
دخول شهرها الرابع دون ان يختلف يومها
الاول عن الحالي وربما التالي اسرائيل
تستبيح كل شيء على رقعه لا تتجاوز مساحتها
كيلومترا هنا مدينه غزه عشرات الشهداء
والمصابين حصدت دبابات اسرائ
بتهمه استلام مواد
اغاثه تناثرت اشلاء مدنيين جوعتهم قوات
الاحتلال وسدت عنهم منافذ الحياه وقصفوا
بقذائف
دبابات ترابد حول المدينه التي قتلت فيها
البشر ولاحقت على درب النزوح جنوبا
وقتلتهم
ايضا وبحلول الخ من يناير يقترب عدد
الشهداء من
ال وغير بعيد من هنا وقبل العمليه البريه
قضت اسرائيل على اخر مخبز في
المدينه كان السكان بانتظار بضع ارغفه
تعينهم على البقاء ذهب المخبز بصاروخ
واستشهد كثير ممن كانوا
ينتظرون ولم يرحل البقيه
ومن غزه التي ستبقى لعنتها تلاحق اسرائيل
الى جنوب القطاع مساحه لا تتجاوز 60
كيلومترا مربعا باتت ملاذا لاكثر من مليون
ونصف مليون فلسطيني بحسب الامم المتحده
تظل المرافق المدنيه هدفا مفضلا لقوات
الاحتلال تشتعل بقصف مدفعي يحصد عشرات
الابريه
شهداء وجرحى في مشهد وكانه يرسم بالنار
كلمات بائسه قالها بنيامين نتنياهو ان
احدا لن يردع اسرائيل لا محكمه العدل ولا
غيرها تطوق دبابات الاحتلال ومدرعاته اخر
المستشفيات القادره على تقديم خدمات طبيه
ناصر والامل في محاولات منها لاقتحام
المدينه
استعصت خانيونس على قوات الاحتلال لاسابيع
فقررت اسرائيل تكرار مشهد الدم في
المعمدان والشفاء والامل واللائحه تطول
وبينما يؤكد نتنياهو ان الحرب مستمره نشرت
صحيفه فورين بوليسي خلاصه دراسه ميدانيه
لمركز ابحاث امريكي وجه سته نصائح
لاسرائيل للنصر في حربها ليس منها وقف
القتل